ABCs of AI n is for natural language
processing NLP is a field of computer
science that focuses on teaching
computers how to interpret manipulate
and understand human language hello
Kit Hello natural language refers to a
language that developed naturally
basically like how you and I talk to
each other versus a created language or
computer code it's a key part of AI
because it can be used to improve the
way we interact with computers and can
help us be more productive efficient and
creative NLP is used to translate
languages extract information from text
convert speech to text and help chat
Bots interact with humans in a more
natural way check out the AI and ml
section of the Google Cloud blog or the
Google AI website for a bunch of
different NLP tutorials and resources
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
the next episode of